that's all you're ever going to have
fun
is there anything that you won't do
like swim with sharks again or something
would you not jump sharks again unless i
have a [ __ ]
protective suit
i'm not [ __ ] with sharks anymore dude
i'm like i [ __ ] tested my boundaries
and
luckily i still have my hand for four uh
people who didn't catch the jackass
shark week episode
i i think
probably like a lot of people know you
got badly bitten by a shark yeah i mean
it was can you show the camera yeah dude
it was it was crazy
i know i felt bad for you guys because
you had to go through it but
[ __ ] i was just like yeah how dare
you do that
that's what he was worried about in the
hospital was so so it's [ __ ] still on
but dude
it's [ __ ] gnarly though which camera
should you show up
it looks like your hand has been like
like burned like freddy krueger yeah
burned that's that's funny because i say
that i tell people it looks like freddy
krueger's face like yeah
yeah did you know that steve his dad is
missing a hand
yeah that's right that's right his poops
always took after his dad my dad got his
hand um ran over by a train let's put it
into perspective how [ __ ] obvious it
was that that was going to happen
this was the thing i had one
i had just i didn't have any practice
runs
well i mean if i would have got a
practice run couple practices wrong with
no sharks i made it no i could have got
no sharks i could have gone it wouldn't
have happened
i mean technically if he would have
landed it and ridden away it would work
[ __ ] amazing but okay so here's the
thing like and it really
like was like supposed to be me because
the bigger bit was a dunk tank built on
on barrels so it was floating so that
the actual tank was the ocean with all
the sharks and i was just
they had this dunk tank with the the
seat above the like six feet above the
water no cage underneath no cage
underneath just barrels on the water and
the seats six feet above and it's got
the target and everyone's supposed to be
throwing chunks of meat
at the target so that the hunks of meat
bring all the sharks and then when one
hunk of meat actually hits the target
it'll drop me into the water and i
thought when i heard the idea i thought
that
that sounded like the safest thing
because when we were in south africa
during the the uh great white they said
if you land on the shark then like
that's the safest thing this it'll
startle the shark like the land in the
water startled the shark it's gonna bolt
so i was like oh dude i'll be perfectly
fine i'll be safe well we get there
and
there was something about these sharks
these caribbean reef sharks doesn't
sound like a scary shark but when we
threw
a piece of meat in the water it was the
gnarliest [ __ ] crap these sharks were
climbing all over each other biting
everything
they were the most aggressive [ __ ]
sharks i've ever seen in my life yeah i
saw a leaf land on the water and it was
wow oh my god
remember when you were feeding them from
the back of the boat gnarliest [ __ ] ever
dude they were it was [ __ ] it was a
frenzy they were gonna feel like a
friend
they put a [ __ ]
uh water ski jump ramp in the water and
now like what we're doing is we're
throwing hunks of meat
right into the to the landing in front
of the ramp so it's just the swarm of
stars
like climbing all over each other to get
that [ __ ] meat what the plus it was
dusk which is when sharks are the most
protected we're losing light and you
don't want to swim at dusk that's the
most dangerous time we've been saying
dude it's dusk like
you know and so we're throwing the
hunks of meat in front of the ramp where
poopies is gonna land what the [ __ ] do
you think is gonna happen every time
something landed in that water
it was like the sharks were conditioned
oh here's we're feeding them right
something lands it's it's it's we eat it
and so we're throwing it we're throwing
it and then the next thing that [ __ ]
lands on that
water is poopies the [ __ ] did you think
was gonna happen oh the only thing that
has landed on that water is food and
then poopies is the next thing to land
he's food he gets bitten was the idea
that he would jump successfully
i wanted to jump over them at least
clear them it was the most [ __ ]
hindsight it was the most reckless most
obvious [ __ ] [ __ ] that put in and had
we
we were supposed to film the dunk tank
before that
and it was the same dynamic if i did the
dunk tank i would have they would have
been throwing everything's food
everything's food and then dropped the
chair and i'm food
when you hit the water
what do you remember
i just remember looking at the boys on
the boat and just
[ __ ] dude i was just like i'm [ __ ]
boys i mean we saw the sharks like he
landed on the sharks we saw them just
[ __ ] commotion is he under water and
then we saw his hand come up out of the
water
and it was
i couldn't say nothing because i was in
shock so i like i was trying to tell him
that i got bit but i like couldn't
really tell
oh [ __ ]
i felt the gums of the mouth like it bit
my hand and i felt the top of the of its
mouth the roof of his mouth with my
fingers was all like slimy and [ __ ] and
that's when i knew i was like i'm
[ __ ] getting bit right now so like
i'm so like i failed to bite and i go
[ __ ] if i like pull my hand off it's
gonna take my hand so i let them have my
hand
you just gave up yeah dude i was just
like dude here's my hand bro
how slow motion this experience is
unfolding because all it was was
for real so yeah and then dude it felt
like the strongest i got full like
it felt like someone grabbed you like
with a [ __ ] robot hand and just like
you have no there's it was so powerful
and so muscular i don't know it was a
straight muscle it felt like a straight
muscle that just can just take my hand
off dude it was so [ __ ] gnarly like
the first thing that we saw like that
where like was poopy's hand come up out
of the water and it's just gushing yeah
it was all and it was just like oh [ __ ]
it was like the gnarliest thing ever and
the actual like it was a wave runner
like jet ski which the medic was driving
to tow poopies on the wakeboard off the
ramp so he was being towed yeah he's
that was his first toe too so so the the
the medic was driving the the jet ski
tows poopies off the ramp sees the
[ __ ] thing and the medic is on the
jet ski turns it around
and drives straight back and dives off
my back
dives on there like dude this medic just
dove into this this mix so [ __ ] fast
saved poopies in such a big way dude
like there's no regard for himself dove
in the mix [ __ ] grab poopies [ __ ]
got just got poopies out of the water
now poopies is climbing on the boat like
if you hold your hand limp right like
hold your hand limp vertical your hand
comes out horizontally take the stranger
so far it can go it's like your hand can
only come out horizontal yeah but
because all of poopy's tendons were
completely severed his hand was flopped
all the way down
like all the way down flat to his
forearm
his hand was flat to his wrist you saw
this steve i saw i saw his hand flopped
all the way down as he got on the boat i
was like oh my god i try to like push up
but it like dude yeah you tried to use
your hand yeah i tried to use my hand
and then i [ __ ] lifted it up and it
fell off and i was like oh [ __ ] dude i
was like this is not good but that guy
saved my life because i don't think if
he if he didn't jump on me i would have
gotten mauled to death yeah i i don't
doubt that i don't doubt that and if
everyone didn't move so [ __ ] fast he
would have bled out definitely he had
his arteries severed was it multiple
arteries
dude i ha i saw blood squirting out like
a perfect straw like you spilled water
out of a straws perfect circle
so you get on the boat they wrap you up
and you're gone like how quickly is that
the medic
bag the medics bag was on another
[ __ ] boat so they're like medic bags
they'd like go
[ __ ] like and it all happened so
[ __ ] fast yeah and the current the
current was [ __ ] so like it took me to
the side of the boat where i'm supposed
to get on it past that so now they're
like pull trying to get me on the boat
and then my wake board gets stuck
between these two yeah he's still on the
wake board and i'm still on the right
board and jeff tremaine's trying to get
the wakeboard off he goes [ __ ] i don't
know the [ __ ] get this wakeboard off
i'm like just chill just heal i'm like
just grab me a [ __ ] towel and so
they've got the wake board off they got
me under the boat and i'm like just give
me the [ __ ] towel everyone's freaking
out they're like they don't know what to
do i'm just give me a [ __ ] towel i
wrap it up and i just [ __ ] hold on
and i i remember one of the camera
divers he just like just slipped just
laying my just laying my arms everybody
was so [ __ ] pro dude i just like it
was it was a double decker boat and i
just went
straight to the top deck just like to
the other side of the boat top deck and
just put had my face in my hands i was
just like jesus yeah i couldn't deal
with it and
what were you thinking steve why i just
i just knew that i didn't add anything
i added no value to this situation
we had the medics we they had they got
the tourniquet going
dude they [ __ ] immediately like had a
you know the speedboat showed up
poopies was on the boat probably in less
than a minute the tourniquet was on you
know like the longest time of that part
was getting the whiteboard off i think
right and i got that off and then it was
just like speedboat medic bag tourniquet
so i had a tourniquet on this arm
right here and then i had a tourniquet
like right here
just to stop the blood flow yeah yeah
and then it [ __ ] but it wasn't like
working that well but yeah luckily they
got a i [ __ ] took a speedboat dude
dude the speedboat came in so hot to the
docks dude we almost [ __ ] like ate
[ __ ] into the docks
and that one bumped my hand too when we
hit the dog
i was like oh
there's like a 10 minute 10 minute boat
ride to the dock and they had a 10
minute boat ride to the dock and then
they had to get me in a van which was
ready to go 20 minutes to the hospital
and then they got me in the hospital and
they're on like lunch break or some [ __ ]
and i got something dude keep in mind
this is the bahamas this is not the most
capable oh [ __ ] hospital right you
know and but they were they were able to
stabilize poopies at the bahamas
hospital and they were like yo
he's got to get air lifted to uh to my
heart yeah
you know because i had to sign myself
out of the hospital because there's this
little asian doctor and he's like
waiting on a phone call to like get the
approval for surgery i'm like dude i'm
not getting surgery in the bahamas and
poopy's dad was at the hospital in the
palms they wouldn't let his dad
a virus they're like no you can't be in
and poop his dad was [ __ ] dude i just
wanted to see someone that i knew like
it was the worst time in my life like
dude oh and when that when when they get
puppies on the speedboat to take him to
the shore
i'm up on the top deck and i see poopies
on the speedboat and i just go poopies i
love you dude
and uh
and [ __ ]
poopies looks up and goes [ __ ] stevo
what the [ __ ] or no you you know he says
he says yo tremaine what the [ __ ] i
better get a bonus for this yeah
yeah
i want a [ __ ] bonus dude
did you get a bonus no
no
[Music]
the medics are doing all their thing
right you got like tremaine's there
you've got like
you know tripp taylor was there
and then you've got like the the
discovery the discovery channel people
there
[ __ ] freaking out there's like the
jackass production team and then there's
the discovery production team which was
just another production company and the
guy the executive producer for this
other production company like whoever
the main guy was he goes oh my god dude
he goes dude oh my god we just we just
ended shark week like there's oh my god
like there's never going to be truck
working the shark we had had gone on for
up to that point 30 years without ever
anybody getting bitten by a shark
and knox was like dude it took us 30
minutes
[Applause]
oh yeah i mean jesus it's the best
documented shark bite clip in history
perhaps perhaps and uh and so like as
soon as this executive producer guy says
dude we just dented shark shark they're
like the shark week's over dude we could
[ __ ] oh my god this is the worst
[ __ ] thing and i said no
immediately this is when i snapped out
of it and i was no longer like shut down
emotionally i snapped out right now i
had value to add
now i felt like i hadn't had my back
dude
immediately i said i said no no the the
the worst thing the only bad thing that
can happen out of this situation is if
that footage doesn't come out
yeah because this footage will make
poopies a legend and the worst possible
tragedy would be if poopies had this
happen to him and then didn't get the
credit this has to [ __ ] come out and
and we will go to war
you know like whatever like because
because that they figured that the show
was going to be shut down everything was
just going to be shut down
and [ __ ] and like i was like nah dude
i'm just i don't know that there would
have been it would have been a lot of
grounds pursuing no i mean i don't want
to do that i'm not that guy anyways they
must have had a lot of views for that
episode right i mean probably the most
it was it was humongously successful for
for
they they were thrilled that was my
debut of jackass
and then the next day
the next day we learned that not only is
shark week not shut down but we're going
to go filming poopies has been air
backed you know to my housing surgery
ruby's had multiple surgeries to
reattach
severed arteries and tendons all my
tendons who knows how you reattach
completely severed arteries but they did
that for two of them it's just insane
and they tell us
hey guys we're going on another shark
tonight
oh yeah the next day you guys went out
huh when you were in miami we went on
another shark dive and they're doing all
these interviews and i'm like that's
funny i'm like dude i mean
[ __ ] that uh
yeah i was just [ __ ] hamming it up i
i was like dude [ __ ] um let's go find
the shark dog
we gotta go get revenge
what that shark did the poopies was not
cool man and we are going back in the
water to find that son of a [ __ ] and
give him a piece of our mind
you know
that was not [ __ ] cool man and we are
gonna go [ __ ] but wait wait but we're
not trying to look for for bad blood we
just want to go squash the beef let me
know that wasn't cool yeah and just
squash the beef yeah yeah yeah like and
i was like and i was like i was like
poop this is probably gonna make a full
recovery and this will be the best thing
that ever happened to him yeah you
filmed that video that night at the
hotel yeah plus he got to ride his first
private jet yeah
there you go yeah yeah it was great yeah
i'm so glad i [ __ ] survived that
thing dude are you glad it i'm glad i
still have my hand though like imagine
if i didn't have a hand dude i would
have been like [ __ ] i'm so glad you
survived that thing too
yeah yeah not sure everything you were
supposed to have it fully back in
october that was now october november
december january february
yeah i'm still going to physical therapy
so so we're six months late and it's not
all the way back six months later dude
it's a shark bite people are like oh
sure they're like they they treat it
like it's not a shark bite it's like
they like treat it like it's a broken
wrist or something i'm like dude you
guys this thing is like this is all it
can do you know like oh my god you don't
have [ __ ] back no dude like i can do
that that and that so if you're just
listening poopy's got about 10 degrees
on going up or down on his wrist and i
can't make a fist
yeah yeah
i can shock her
that's that's [ __ ] heartbreaking but
but you've been back in the water you're
able to surf yeah yeah i [ __ ] my
first time surfing wasn't in like in
october after my birthday oh so you did
serve on schedule i did surf on schedule
and it wasn't like it wasn't really like
pumping surfing it was more like
trying to see how much weight my wrist
can take did you serve pipeline nope not
yet
not yet pipelines gnarly pipelines
when i get a good pipeline barrel i'll
be so [ __ ] pumped but we're still
working on that
dude like you're you're not back your
wrist is i'm not back dude like i can't
even write a short board like i have to
soft top every time
like i said that's so [ __ ]
heartbreaking man
how did that happen i remember i felt
guilty and i had [ __ ] like no i don't
know why the [ __ ] i would feel guilty i
didn't [ __ ]
i felt really [ __ ]
awful about the situation and and i was
uh i was like dude [ __ ] discoveries
gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat this i knew
because when we filmed the end of that
episode they were trying to play it down
like oh yeah
recovery like this that and and i it was
really important to me
that you'd be able to tell that story
like actually as it happened and so i
reached out to
certain people who had the raw footage
yep and i got legend both underwater
camera angles all of the raw footage of
the bite all of everything everything
like the gnarliest
and the gnarly clip that discovery
didn't use it was like too gnarly for
them yes yeah this stuff like so that
poopies can the the real story of how it
went down and and i went around in one
day i went around and i filmed knoxville
and tremaine and jasper who was there
everybody who was there and i did my own
little interview with them so awesome
and then poopies did his own interview
to tell the story and we put together
this phenomenal phenomenal video yeah
about all of our perspectives on the
attack and poopy in that poopy's telling
that was that like the first time you
told the story because poopies broke
down and [ __ ] well yeah like the
first time i told the story out of a
discovery dude that's it we're linking
that
you put it on your chanel
that has over a million views yeah baby
hell yeah
i know you're glad you survived right
but like is there any part of you that
you're glad you got bit
there is there is dude like because like
like imagine my story is like
i [ __ ] got bit by a shark i jumped a
[ __ ] shark pit like fonzie was gonna
like fonzie did you know i like fonzie
dead now not like
[Music]
pit with a wake foreign and [ __ ]
didn't land it and got bit and i'm lit
i'm here to tell the story right i don't
think there's anyone in the world has
ever [ __ ] jumped a shark pit
not like you have not like me yeah yeah
and the bite i mean yeah it is
heartbreaking but it's also it's it's
definitely like it adds to my legacy
dude it adds to my legacy man wait what
are you limited in doing like we've
established the surfing pipeline so
there's like surfing pipes short
boarding big waves um
there's there's there's times where i'm
like trying to open the door with my
keys and like i got groceries and i
can't get my keys and like are there's
times where i'm like trying to get
something on my backpack and my arm my
wrist doesn't reach that far so there's
all these little things these little
tiny things that you wouldn't think of
that would [ __ ] suck and you told me
yeah
okay you told me that
you asked trained to line you up with
stem cell therapy yeah yeah i want to go
because when you're texting with your
phone your your hand hurts you yeah so
like in the morning time it's fine like
i'll wake up in the morning and it feels
great you know and then i'll wake up
take my shower and i'll get on my phone
and when i'm on my phone it's just like
from just like texting and typing like
my emails and [ __ ] or just liking stuff
and
it just starts hurting so then i get
this ache in my hand and i get i can't
use it and then it's like [ __ ] well i
have to use it like i have to my whole
day ahead of me you know yeah you got to
be swiping on tinder
yeah
i linked you up with michael at bile
accelerator yeah you can talk to him
yeah i have i have and i'm let's give
them a shout out bio accelerator
yeah bioaccelerator dude i'm coming for
you guys you guys are going to help me
out so much i'm so stoked that you guys
want to help me can you do a like a
push-up or is that like two
no
he's been practicing like with
missionary sex yeah just try to
do some pumps and yeah so yeah
elbows if you have absolutely it would
help so much though because it would
stretch it and dude it would hurt so
much though but i was like i know this
is is good for it because it's
stretching it so now
i can [ __ ] put my wrist all the way
like that wow so straight boning like
was the best physical therapy either
yeah it was and like i would tell people
that and they thought it was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but it's a good pick-up line you
know yeah dude it would too because i'd
put so much weight on because i'm trying
to nut too and like get in that zone you
know you're like yeah come on
a lot of pressure on it and then you
know and then it's like i finally not
and it's like [ __ ] finally i gotta like
roll over and like hold my hand i'm like
oh [ __ ] babe that was great
but you're getting a frenzy yeah but
yeah i [ __ ] helped out a lot dude so
that that kind of i was like as long as
i can get my wrist to do that because i
can need to stand up on my surfboard i'm
fine and missionary helped out so much
i don't think i shouldn't be
i don't think i should have been doing
that at that time but dude
i was like i have to not right now and
yeah that's how i like to nut as
missionary so
so what what is the physical therapist
and the doctor is telling you
dude
the physical therapist is so fried they
keep doing the same [ __ ] and doing the
same [ __ ] and i'm like dude it's a
[ __ ] shark bite dude it's ain't no
normal injury you know my doctor is like
poopies dude
you're a [ __ ] man dude you're the man
and he helps me out i see him every
three weeks dr dan
every three weeks you're coming up to la
to go to like the foremost hand doctor
in the world yeah yeah so he has his um
his assistant which is a legend too
and he checks i go to orange county at
his office okay he checks it out but he
said it's pretty much that's all i got
that's all you're ever going to have
fun yeah
so
that's what i wasn't hoping for but i
mean that's how it just happened but is
it going to get stronger to where you
can
are you telling me you'll never be able
to surf a short board again in your life
no i will
i mean how's that girl bethany do it
what's the girl with one eye she's
gnarly dude so so i have yeah she's not
she's inspiration to me
because she's got one arm dude and she's
standing up at pipe yeah shout out to
bethany bethany hamilton you are a
legend if you can i just watched a
documentary on an airplane and i was
really [ __ ] she's gnarly dude she's
gnarly yeah she's red she's rad i've
never really got to meet her like in
person the difference for you though is
that if you land on it bad that it's
fragile it's it's like you know oh yeah
because look how small it is between
this arm and that arm if you're a pipe
and you wipe out your f
yeah if i yeah i can't swim yeah so so
the hand is actually a liability where
if it wasn't there there would be no you
might want to get that like a vest that
you can
[Music]
dude it really [ __ ] breaks my heart
to to learn that dude
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]
me